one year into the pandemic and it's been
marked by many milestones for one family
it's a year
they almost didn't have together denise
brings us their story in today's health
watch denise
well christian a southern california
mother and her baby are finally home
today after they both nearly died from
coped 19.
just as they were starting their life
together they faced their biggest battle
i am ecstatic we've been waiting for
this moment
for quite some time now that is yvette
camacho smiling no doubt under that mask
as she wheeled her newborn daughter
emery out of the hospital
now yvette has been battling covet since
january
at just 30 years old she had no
pre-existing conditions other than her
pregnancy
she was so sick she had to be airlifted
to cedars-sinai medical center and put
on life support
her baby needed to be delivered right
away at just 26 weeks
if she had not come to us or even if we
delayed
the the transfer for whatever reason i
don't think that
unfortunately either her or baby would
have survived this
well she woke up a week later wasn't
even aware of the delivery her only
contact with her little newborn was over
face time
one month and just two pounds later
emery was strong enough to leave the
hospital
today doctors are still searching though
why some pregnant women with no
pre-existing conditions can get
so sick with covid so it is recommended
that pregnant women talk to their
doctors about whether they should get
the coping vaccine